l'aquila sia adesso
ma che vi viene in mente sicuramente il
il terremoto che dal 2009 ha distrutto
la nel 2009 ha distrutto la mia città
però prima di tornare se facessimo un
passo indietro e tornassimo a prima di
quella data del 2009 quando si parlava
dell'aquila si pensava due cose la prima
che insieme a potenza contendeva il
primato è la città più fredda d'italia
la seconda cosa che veniva in mente
invece era associare l'aquila alla sua
squadra di rugby perché l'aquila e rugby
è un sinonimo che lega e questo
territorio questo tessuto sociale e che
lo vede dentro nel proprio dna ma voglio
tornare nel 2008 alla mia esperienza
personale diretta sono in sudafrica sono
a pretoria
stiamo preparando la partita con gli
springbok perché conosce quella realtà
pretoria è una città molto difficile ci
avevano fatto delle belle lezioni su
come andare in giro perché una città
pericolosa una città dove ci sono
parecchi omicidi perché rapine bisognava
stare molto attenti quando la gente si
avvicina va bene noi eravamo sul cavo
avevano appena finito l'allenamento i
ragazzi stavano raccogliendo il
materiale del campo noi stavamo parlando
stanno facendo un de briefing con il
resto dello staff si avvicina un
ragazzino di colore si avvicina il
ragazzo parla in inglese cerca di dire
qualcosa ma non riusciamo a capire il
suo inglese
noi non riusciamo a comprenderlo ci
guardiamo un po in faccia il ragazzo
ripete queste parole ma noi non
riusciamo proprio a capire quello che
dice che uno dello dello staff dice
guarda ci dispiace ma facendo un passo
indietro dice guarda non abbiamo soldi
non abbiamo nulla dietro di noi perché
abbiamo lasciato tutto in camera siamo
qui per fare allenamento il ragazzo si
avvicina e spiega molto più lentamente e
dice io non ho bisogno di soldi
ho bisogno di un opportunità per
cambiare la mia vita
questa lezione miei mi è rimasta dentro
e la porto sempre dentro con me perché
il rischio che aveva preso questo
ragazzo entrare in questo centro di alta
per di alta prestazione sudafricani del
rischio che aveva preso per poter avere
un'opportunità per cambiare la vita
sicuramente qualcosa che che ti tocca
che ti rimane dentro per tutta la vita e
adesso voglio tornare nel 2014 nel 2014
e concludo le mie esperienze con le
varie realtà e tornò a l'aquila torna
all'aquila da esiliato dopo cinque anni
dove ho vissuto girando il mondo con le
federe con la nazionale ma anche vivendo
fuori dalla mia città torna all'aquila e
mi rendo conto che l'aquila è una città
in fermento perché la ricostruzione è in
atto e avviata e c'è un grandissimo
fermento sotto il profilo diciamo della
ricostruzione ma mi rendo anche conto
dopo pochi giorni dopo pochi mesi che
vivono in città della grandissima
difficoltà che sia nel relazionarsi con
le persone
abbiamo perso tutto in quella notte ma
soprattutto a mio avviso abbiamo perso i
rapporti interpersonali abbiamo perso la
capacità di relazionarsi come uomini
come persone e il rugby che era un punto
di riferimento stava passando un periodo
bruttissimo
tant'è che nel 2016 l'aquila retrocede
dalla massima serie retrocede nella
categoria inferiore e lì io vengo
chiamato dall'allora presidente mauro
zaffiri che mi invita a dargli una mano
ea cercare di portare un cambiamento
all'interno della sua organizzazione
un'organizzazione che nel tempo era
andato sempre scemando e avvenuto sempre
di più problemi soprattutto economici mi
chiede di fare un progetto per questa
per questa nuova realtà mi dice vincenzo
tu hai le capacità e le esperienze per
poter cambiare il corso della nostra
della nostra società ci rifletto un
attimo ma ci pensa davvero poco perché
per me è un'opportunità
anzi per me sono due opportunità la
prima opportunità e personale
mi sono sempre chiesto
tutto lontano dalla mia città cosa io
avrei potuto fare per la mia città bene
quella era un'opportunità per dare il
mio contributo alla mia esperienza a
mettere a disposizione della della mia
città il mio talento
la seconda opportunità era davvero poter
aiutare questa società a tornare a
essere tra le prime società in italia
ciò che nel tempo il tempo aveva
dimenticato ed è così li accetto
l'incarico e decidiamo insieme al
presidente di parlare con i giocatori la
maggior parte di questi giocatori
decidono di abbandonare la squadra
perché scendendo di categoria avrebbero
perso lì visibilità
rimangono solo sedici atleti aquilani i
più giovani quelli che forse non avevano
l'opportunità di scegliere squadre
migliori cerchiamo decidiamo di puntare
su di loro ma la rosa è troppo è troppo
corta e allora io penso che di andare in
giro
avendo avuto l'esperienza con con le
varie nazionali mi ricordavo che c'erano
degli atleti che avevano avuto talento
qualcuno di loro aveva perso la strada
era dimenticato che il proprietà lento
avrebbe potuto essere per loro un
opportunità ancora di crescita lì
contatto gli chiedo gli dico che sto
facendo questo progetto
in questa città o delle adesioni
la maggior parte di questi ragazzi sono
studenti universitari
la società propone loro un appartamento
condiviso e ogni piccolo rimborso spese
250 euro per gli atleti dell'aquila 400
euro erano gli atleti che vengono fuori
l'aquila venivano all'aquila per giocare
ma veniamo l'aquila anche per studiare
grazie all'università forte che abbiamo
in città importante che abbiamo città
per cui chiedo loro di provare a mettere
in gioco le loro competenze mettere in
gioco e metterle in gioco per la nostra
città per avere un'opportunità personale
di poter continuare quel percorso che
probabilmente avevano un po perso
e per dare l'opportunità alla nostra
città di cambiare il percorso la storia
che stava che aveva ormai aveva preso e
così decidiamo mettiamo giù una squadra
vengono a darci una mano 14 ragazzi che
vengono da altre realtà delle varie
parti d'italia
e ci mettiamo su bere al lavoro dal
primo aspetto il primo lavoro che faccio
cerco di fissare con loro degli
obiettivi gli obiettivi io ho degli
obiettivi la mia società degli obiettivi
ma per me era importante sentire i loro
obiettivi quindi chiedo ogni giocatore
di parlarmi di sé di parlarmi di quelli
che potrebbero essere stati gli
obiettivi sarebbero stati gli obiettivi
della stagione e dopo aver parlato con
tutti viene fuori questo viene fuori una
cosa fortissima e quindi così come la
mia città così come la come la come la
mia società
anche loro volevano approfittare di un
cambiamento per ritrovare la propria
identità di atleti di alto livello
perché erano tutti stati atleti di alto
livello le avevamo allenati nelle varie
nazionali accademie della nazionale
italiana e per trovare la propria
identità in campo e fuori dal campo
e in più e questa è una cosa molto
straordinaria che ognuno di loro aveva
la voglia di battersi per la nostra
città per la sua gente perché gli
avevano raccontato delle nostre
difficoltà e avevamo raccontato avevano
visto con i loro occhi quello che era la
nostra città e quanta sofferenza era
sulle spalle sui volti di questa della
nostra gente
fissati gli obiettivi spetta a me spetta
a me e al mio modo di gestire la mia
squadra e metto la strada e metto e
indico la strada ai nostri ragazzi e
dico questo questo è un mio pensiero io
sono convinto che gli attriti
all'interno di una squadra debba
sentirsi liberi di fare delle proprie
scelte ma devono rispettare i principi
comuni di gioco e rispettare gli
obiettivi che la squadra si è prefissato
che il gruppo si è prefissato quindi si
è liberi all'interno di regole precise
che ci siamo gettati all'interno del
nostro gruppo è ancora qui
metto la mia esperienza a disposizione
per poter indicare la propria identità
per poter ritrovare la propria identità
il primo aspetto che metto è la
disponibilità
bisogna essere disponibili a un
cambiamento
il secondo aspetto che chiedo è la parte
che mi interessa molto di più quando mi
si chiede che cosa fai
qual è il diciamo che cosa fa un
allenatore io penso che l'allenatore sia
colui che individui dei talenti e chiede
alla propria squadra di condividere i
propri talenti con l'allenatore con lo
staff con i compagni di squadra
la disponibilità della condivisione dei
talenti porta sicuramente un risultato
collettivo disponibilità condivisione
rispetto e ancora coerenza lavoro work
reit lavoro intensità del lavoro e
fiducia questi sono gli aspetti che deve
avere questo gruppo di lavoro per
incominciare a produrre dei risultati e
risultati incominciano arrivare perché
riusciamo a vincere 14 partite su 15
incontri
c'è entusiasmo pensate che nella partita
più importante di questa prima fase del
nostro campionato giochiamo un derby e
sugli spalti ci sono 2.500 spettatori
l'aquila nel tempo aveva 100 200 300 al
massimo spettatori siamo riusciti a
portare un po di entusiasmo e
soprattutto l'aspetto più importante che
ci interessava di più siamo riusciti ad
avvicinare a riavvicinare al campo delle
persone significa per noi ricollegare
rimettere energia elettrica in quel
circuito emozionale che portava la gente
al campo a vedere ea sorridere a
soffrire per la propria squadra è il
primo passo per un rapporto relazionale
tra ciò che è stato il rugby è ciò che è
stata la cittadella
arrivano i risultati
e purtroppo a gennaio arriva la prima
inter parliamo di interferenze un altro
aspetto che io che io metto a fuoco
quando stiamo organizzando la squadra
sono e questa formula è una formula
matematica dove per p maiuscola intendo
le potenzialità la somma dei talenti dei
nostri giocatori per i sono le
interferenze sono quelle quei
comportamenti autolimitanti e
soprattutto sono quelli alibi che
normalmente un atleta porta avanti nel
momento in cui incontra le prime
difficoltà lavoro su questo aspetto
lavoriamo con tutto lo staff su questi
aspetti per cercare di risolvere questi
interferenze che impediscono la nostra
scuola di avere delle grandi prestazioni
all'atleta de vedere buone prestazioni e
la scuola di conseguenza di avere delle
prestazioni in più ci sono le
interferenze esterne le interferenze
esterne che possono essere le lascio
immaginare da dalle difficoltà
logistiche dalle difficoltà economiche
dalle difficoltà di qualsiasi tipo non
ultime le difficoltà meteo
quando giochi una partita e piove
sicuramente una gara diversa e di quando
c'è il sole
bene se noi se io non fossi stato in
grado di abbassare queste interferenze
avrei avuto un potenziale depotenziato
ecco perché a volte parliamo di talento
sprecato il talento si spreca quando ci
sono delle interferenze che si
interpongono subito sul tuo cammino il
mio lavoro più grande la mia esperienza
mi ha portato a lavorare su questi
ragazzi su questo aspetto è sicuramente
questo ci ha portato i risultati e come
dicevo vinciamo 14 partite su 15
ma la prima interferenza esterna a
gennaio il presidente comuni che
giocatori che non è in grado di pagare
il rimborso delle spese è un dramma per
tutti un dramma per noi che abitiamo
all'aquila il relativo non era un grosso
rimborso spese
era una cosa simbolica ma per chi veniva
da fuori per chi doveva affrontare le
spese per vivere la nostra città
sarebbe stato un problema riuniamo la
squadra ci mettiamo nello spogliatoio e
tiriamo fuori tutte le problematiche
decidiamo di andare avanti
decide di andare avanti e semplice molti
di questi ragazzi che venivano da fuori
facevano l'università quindi fermarsi
all'università con l'università a
gennaio sarebbe stato un problema
decidiamo ad andare avanti ma tutti
insieme decidiamo che l'incasso della
domenica che non è così elevato perché
andare a vedere una partita di rugby
costa dai 510 euro quindi non è che
avevamo degli incassi importanti ma con
la società diciamo decidiamo che gli
incassi vengono dati solo esclusivamente
i giocatori che arrivano da fuori in
modo da poter mangiare e poter
continuare la loro vita in modo più
semplice più sereno possibile
bene decidiamo queste sapete cosa
succede che i ragazzi che vengono da
fuori due volte a settimana
cucinano per tutta la squadra invitano i
ragazzi a squadra della squadra e
limitano a casa loro
cucinano e mangiano insieme e questo per
noi per il nostro gruppo
incomincia a consolidarsi ancora di più
nella condivisione di quel poco di bene
che è che gli era rimasto ancora
continuiamo a darci qualcosa in campo
continua arrivare delle delle partite
siamo nella seconda fase anche qui
perdiamo due gare con una squadra
fortissima che è stata già costruita per
salire di categoria
immaginate noi prendiamo un rimborso
spese minimo loro hanno speso 800 mila
euro per fare una squadra per salire su
la perdiamo combattiamo ma sono più
forti di noi però ci tocca andare a
giocare a recco una partita
importantissima questa partita decide se
siamo nei nei play off a giocarci la
semifinale o meno vinciamo a recco
vinciamo a recco 8 a 6
torniamo a casa e alle otto di alle 2 di
notte nelle otto di mattina mi chiamano
vincenzo hanno staccato la corrente
elettrica dei nostri appartamenti
mentre i giornali parlavano di
entusiasmo di una squadra che era andata
a vincere fuori che aveva riportato
entusiasmo che la città era in fermento
che ci stavano seguendo noi all'interno
avevamo un altro dragone c'era è venuta
fuori un'altra interferenza fortissima
di nuovo lì riunione che facciamo non ce
la facciamo più siamo stremati molti
decidono che vogliono andare via la
maggior parte decide che è tanto è
arrivato aprile ormai quello che è fatto
è fatto vogliamo andare via però
qualcuno vuole resistere mancano tre
settimane perché vincendo questa partita
deve ancora finire anzi sono
piacerebbero state delle due partite di
semifinale stringiamo i denti ragazzi
stringiamo i denti ci viene in mente una
cosa diversa del momento di contrà di
ricambiare quello che ci avevano dato
questi ragazzi seri se vi ricordate uno
dei loro obiettivi era battersi per
questa gente battersi per la mia gente
battersi per la mia città loro erano
venuti a battersi a mettere la loro
pelle le loro ossa per la mia città è il
momento di dare qualcosa a loro
decidiamo tutti insieme noi aquilani di
adottare un atleta e portarselo a casa
a me ne spettano 21 come allenatore è
uno come padre di atleta della della
squadra che decide comunque di portare a
casa un'altra atleta non è un problema
mangiamo quello che abbiamo mangiano
tutti quello che abbiamo ma era un
diritto di questi ragazzi essere
ricambiati per quello che stiamo facendo
con per noi andiamo avanti teniamo duro
affrontiamo la prima partita di
semifinale con il valsugana padova
affrontiamo questa prima partita la
vinciamo siamo stati bravissimi una
squadra fortissima di fronte la squadra
che abbiamo incontrato perdeva per la
prima volta dopo ventisei gare
consecutive vinte ha perso per la prima
volta a l'aquila l'aquila mette ancora
molto terrore nelle nelle gambe degli
avversari che vengono che scendono sul
campo
tommaso fattori ma era il momento di
andare a padova
andiamo a padova e giochiamo la nostra
partita
entriamo in campo fiduciosi di quello
che avevamo fatto fino fino all'ora ma
avevamo visto che di fronte avevamo una
squadra forte che non era poi così
facile da battere
bisognava ripetersi ancora a padova e
non era semplice dopo venti minuti di
gioco
21 a 0 per loro sarebbe bastato una meta
noi saremmo rimaste andati fuori dalle
avremmo finito il nostro cammino
riusciamo a segnare una meta 21 a 7
finisce il primo tempo 21 a 7 raduno la
squadra molto serafico molto calma e
dico ragazzi grazie
cosa devo dirvi grazie
avete fatto tutto quello che poteva te
il nostro campionato finisce qui
a meno che non decidiate di mettere da
parte le paure e di provare a giocare la
partita questo è il risultato finale
33 a 21 per noi lasciamo entrare in
campo e non fargli fare nessun punto
riusciamo a fare tutto quello che fino a
quel momento ci aveva bloccato
non ho urlato non ho avuto bisogno di
stimolarle ancora di più
sono andato a toccare quelle corde
emozionali che erano fondamentali per
ritrovare il talento che avevano
dimostrato fino a quel momento è che per
un attimo sembrava perso
è la gioia più grande di tutti in questa
fotografia si può vedere la serenità che
questi ragazzi ci hanno messo hanno
addosso
l'argento vivo che hanno addosso perché
sono andati oltre quel risultato oltre
una partita persa
ho messo questa frase che è di seneca
perché la trovo molto aderente a quello
che è il mio pensiero di resilienza la
resilienza in gergo tecnico e la
capacità di un materiale di resistere a
delle sollecitazioni i nostri ragazzi
hanno resistito a moltissime
sollecitazioni ma a volte le
specializzazioni non servono solo a
testardi
ma servono davvero a darti la strada
giusta
a indicarci la strada per raggiungere il
tuo obiettivo
e i nostri ragazzi sono sono stati in
grado di raggiungere quell'obiettivo
al di là del risultato finale
al di là che la società oggi non esiste
più ne esiste un'altra nuova perché due
mesi dopo quella quella partita di
padova il nostro presidente colto un
malore che si è rifatto vivo alla
portato via e nessuno è stato in grado
di portare avanti quella esperienza si è
passati si è deciso di passare su
un'altra esperienza non è un problema
i nostri ragazzi hanno condiviso
tutt'oggi condividono un social dove
ognuno di loro racconta le proprie
esperienze e le proprie difficoltà a
distanza siamo riusciti a costruire una
squadra diffusa sul territorio
tutti i ragazzi che hanno giocato con
noi oggi gioca nella categoria superiore
la categoria che sempre che sempre
magari avrebbero potuto giocare ma che
per un momento avevano dimenticato di
essere a 3d di quel livello lì
allora dico che quando un progetto è in
grado di coinvolgere e soprattutto di
emozionare gli attori dell'impresa e
quando le competenze le intelligenze e
le conoscenze vengono messe vengono
condivise con gli altri e messe sotto un
obiettivo più grande è per noi
l'obiettivo più grande quella maglia
perché quella maglia rappresenta una
città rappresenta l'orgoglio di quella
città
allora sì che si possono fare si possono
ottenere dei risultati allora sì che il
22 a volte vale 5 mila show un filmato e
poi concludiamo